you're listening to what azeem rafiq had  to say i thought it was heart-rending  testimony i want to thank him for his  bravery for being so open about the the  racism that he sadly has suffered and  i've got to say when i was listening to  him it reminded me of much of the racism  i suffered as a child but know that was  30 or 40 years ago thankfully the  country's you know come a long way since  then i think we're one of the most  successful multi-racial societies in the  world but from his testimony that  clearly isn't the case for every  institution in the uk and clearly  yorkshire county club is is obvious it's  institutionally racist and that  something needs to be done and i hope  that anyone that's still involved  from the time that he was at that club  is reflecting on his testimony and  thinking about why they turned a blind  eye for the uh  against what he was suffering